braucht der klimaschutz die atomenergie
nein sagt armin simon er ist anti atom
aktivist und hat so gut wie keinen
castor-transport verpasst seine meinung
ist ziemlich klar schreibt einigen
jahren engagiere mich bei ausgestrahlt
dafür dass die letzten atomkraftwerke
endlich vom netz gehen und freue mich
wenn das ende des jahres der fall ist er
trifft auch florian krist der vorstand
reaktorsicherheit und ist aktiv in der
kerntechnischen gesellschaft und spricht
sich für die nutzung von kernenergie
auch
noch für eine gewisse zeit gebrauchen
gerade die letzten drei reaktoren die
noch am netz sind weil ich denke dass
sie uns in der aktuellen situation
helfen können wir schicken zwei menschen
mit unterschiedlichen meinungen zu
dieser frage auf einen rutsch beide
wissen nicht auf wen sie treffen oder
was heute passiert nur dass ihr ihn am
ende die frage stellen trefft ihr euch
in der mitte gibt es eine grauzone wir
sind uns auch einig dass wir möglichst
viele erneuerbare energien möglichst
schnell haben wollen natürlich braucht
es noch ein paar jahre ich bin ich
überzeugt davon dass wir die fahrzeuge
hätten um klären müssen wer ist das sagt
kohler
ich habe da eine ganz klare handelt so
die bei der atom das ist es doch so wenn
es zu einem schweren unfall kommt dann
hat man doch wirklich ein riesiges
problem das will man nicht also gerade
die deutschen anlagen das ist
für punkt über den wir auf jeden fall
diskutieren
sollten wir die andere reaktoren ab die
die sichersten der welt sind die die
noch gar nicht so alt sind also die
die jetzt noch mal auf 89 jahren gebaut
worden aber das problem ist ja
so eine anlage kommt doch nie an den an
den punkt wo jemand sagt gut das ist
aber zu unsicher das ist sie mal
abschalten sondern im zweifelsfall
passiert es doch immer erst dann wenn es
eben zu spät ist es gibt ja auf jeden
fall jährlich diese revision damit
wer dieses herz untersuchen
aber alle 400 atomkraftwerke weltweit
laufen dann würden sowohl der betreiber
als auch die aufsichtsbehörden würden
hier heute alle unterschreiben dass
diese alle 400 anlagen in einem sicheren
zustand sind sonst dürften sehr gar
nicht laufen und auch der betreiber von
fukushima hätte noch am 10 märz 2011
unterschrieben dass eine anlage in
absolut sicheren zustand des und einen
tag später sind genug geführt
unser erster stopp liegt am windpark
königshof in der höhe bei bedburg
zwischen köln und mönchengladbach hier
stehen auf etwa 345 hektar fläche 21
baugleiche windenergieanlagen das
besondere da wo jetzt windräder stehen
befand sich früher der stadtteil
königshofen und darunter einiges an
braunkohle
war er wie immer sie auch zum jagen
getragen werden sagt ja und ihr habt ja
auch nur deswegen so weil ihnen jetzt
unmissverständlich deutlich gemacht
wurde dass die kohleverstromung ein ende
haben muss
dann bleibt ihm ja nichts anderes übrig
als auch erneuerbare zu machen also auch
der kohleausstieg sagt man dass es jetzt
druck gibt zu seinen politischen druck
die kohleverstromung zu reduzieren auch
der ist ja geht ja zurück auf den
öffentlichen druck den den die
klimagerechtigkeit bewegung jetzt
erzeugt hat ja auch da gibt es seit seit
ich selber auch schon ein kohlezug
blockiert übrigens mit den erfahrungen
der castor-transporte und
es gab ja hier in garzweiler gab es doch
cohens und sonstige riesige aktionen im
besetzungen von den von den tagebau
baggern usw
hambacher forst die welt besetzung und
so weiter und das haben wir halt in den
meisten anderen staaten noch nicht und
da ist das auch mit der klimadebatte
noch an einem anderen stand und deswegen
denke ich dass wir im moment sagen wir
mal sagen wir jetzt einfach mal weltweit
gesehen
von der kernenergie noch nicht runter
kommen soll wenn wir das machen würden
dann würden wir automatisch mehr kohle
verfeuern oder andere fossile energie
trägt hier in nrw geht beispielsweise
die abstandsregel ein gesetz das besagt
dass windräder 1000 meter von
wohnhäusern entfernt liegen müssen der
bund ist zwar dran diese regel
auszuhebeln aber stand jetzt gilt sie
noch er steht drin dass wir die gesamte
strommenge die in akw erzeugt unter der
voraussetzung dass es läuft auf der
fläche von ungefähr recklinghausen
erzeugen können vorausgesetzt
man halt dreimal recklinghausen ja
tragen wir brauchen ein paar anlagen das
stimmt schon aber man hat danach sind
einfach strom einfach so also wir haben
natürlich eine enorme energiedichte wird
erklären es sind die flächen wo es uran
fördert und wo man den müll lagert und
das muss man also damit rechnen aber ja
nein aber es gibt ja diese untersuchen
die gibt's schon lange vom
umweltbundesamt und jetzt hat es die
bundesregierung ja nochmal bestätigt
dass man um die zwei prozent der
landesfläche braucht man wenn man
deutschland erneuerbar versorgen will
und das ist erst mal viel fläche aber
auch nie wann sie die firma wir geben
aber wir haben auch fläche die wir mit
straßen zu bauen und sonst irgendwas und
und es ist ein weg sein dass das ganze
gebiet hier zählt dann sozusagen als
windkraft genutzte fläche aber die
fläche ist ja nicht weg sie ist ja doch
trotzdem immer noch da und man kann hier
gemüse anbauen also es gibt ja
regelmäßige meinungsumfragen zur
akzeptanz von erneuerbaren energien und
diesem jahr erstaunlich hoch die sind
bei 70 80 prozent und zwar auch wenn es
darum geht sind sie einverstanden damit
dass erneuerbare energien in ihrem
direkten umfeld
genutzt werden aber sicherlich mit einem
gewissen abstand also wenn ich jetzt das
hier nehme das klingt schon wie so ein
flugzeug das einfach so dauerhaft dort
sind aber deutlich näher dran als 1000
meter jetzt ja das schon ja aber das ist
diese abstandsregel braucht aber darauf
wollte ich nur hinaus das gibt immer
diese auf schreier also egal um welche
veränderungen es geht aber wann sind die
leute einfach standen wenn irgendwie so
90 prozent damit einverstanden sind oder
alle oder die frage ob ich mit was
einverstanden bin oder ob ich bereit bin
was zu akzeptieren die hängt ja manchmal
auch davon ab was ich davon bekommen ja
also es gibt zur projekte zum beispiel
wo dann die das dorf miteigentümer der
des windparks wird und dann kriegen die
dann kriegen die profitieren die
praktisch von den von den erlösen des
windparks wie du sagst da sollte ein
konsens da sein und ich glaube da
sondern auch uns darüber einig dass es
dann gewisse regelungen braucht die auch
irgendwo ein stückweit nicht zu
kompliziert sind klar sind und 700 meter
sind oder 1000 das kann man immer
diskutieren das sind dann auch wieder so
diese politischen entscheidung nach dem
windpark geht es für die beiden weiter
zu jemandem der sich mit den negativen
folgen von atomkraft auf eine ganz
andere art beschäftigt hat
die kernenergie nutzen also die trägt
nicht dazu bei
den klimawandel zu bekämpfen
dann muss man sich doch nur mal
vorstellen da was würde dann bedeuten
wenn jetzt frankreich china usa wenn die
ihre kraftwerke von jetzt auf nachher
durch kohlekraftwerke ersetzen würden
wenn es geht doch darum wir müssen doch
die energiewende hinkriegen energiewende
heißt wir müssen umsteigen auf
erneuerbare energien und wir haben ja
nur begrenzte mengen geld zur verfügung
wenn man nicht unendlich viel geld und
die frage ist doch investiere ich jetzt
geld was ich jetzt habe in forschung und
neubau von neuen reaktoren oder baue ich
einfach windkraftanlagen und solarpanel
das heißt also wenn die lösung darin
besteht die kraftwerke so schnell wie
möglich abzuschalten und durch
erneuerbare zu ersetzen dann sagte ich
das wird nicht gelingen nicht
kurzfristig
weil die kernkraftwerke banken durch
andere konventionelle kraftwerke ersetzt
werden muss ich sehe da immer noch das
potenzial der kernenergie darin das ist
einfach eine eine der wenigen co2 arm
möglichkeiten ist strom zu erzeugen wir
haben dann auch
wasserkraft ja noch biogas
wind und sonne ist nicht ist nicht
grundlastfähig wir brauchen keine
grundlast mehr wir brauchen nur
wir brauchen nur irgendwas was sie
kurzzeitigen lücken ja aber die ist
nicht warum steht seit ich im moment
sind den ich kurzzeitig im moment
brauche ich also kannst auch sicherlich
denn den strommix in deutschland da kann
man sich bei zb zeit online kann man
sich denn auch tagesaktuell verhindert
das ist ja nicht so dass wir darüber
sprechen dass wir hier nur noch so ganz
kleinen anteil an
konventioneller energieerzeugung haben
sondern der ist immer noch sehr gut aber
das sieht man ja dass schon in
schon im sommer sozusagen regelmäßig um
die mittagszeit herum gibt es sozusagen
so viel mehr strom als verbraucht aber
das reicht uns nicht wir brauchen da
rund um die uhr aber grundlaststrom hieß
ja dass ich in kraft gebraucht ist die
ganze zeit durchläuft das stimmt ja gar
nicht ich brauche nur eins was nachts
also abends vielleicht ein bisschen also
wenn wenn jemand ein super speicher
entwickelt mit dem man überschussstrom
speichern kann
dann wird er sich eine goldene nase
verdienen unsere zweite station liegt in
würselen bei aachen nur 100 kilometer
von hier befindet sich das belgische
kernkraftwerke dass man aufgrund seiner
zahlreichen störfälle hier auch brückl
reaktor nennt deswegen sind die menschen
hier besorgt einer von ihnen ist markus
bertram der für alle 1200 kinder einer
schule ein notfallkonzept entwickelt hat
für den ernstfall was würde eigentlich
passieren wenn der reaktor kaputt geht
wer rettet uns denn dann wenn wir
irgendwo da sind ich würde sagen dass in
einer solchen er von panik durchsetzten
situation ein objektives handeln
eigentlich kaum noch möglich ist also
haben wir uns entschieden auch wenn die
wahrscheinlichkeit sehr sehr sehr gering
ist dass wir uns im vorfeld gedanken
machen wir sind der meinung dass wir
durch dieses konzept uns etwas überlegt
haben was zumindest in der schwierigsten
stunde die wir hier dann letztendlich
haben uns eine handreichung gibt
wenigstens zu wissen geht es in
angehörigen sprich den kindern in der
schule gut wir haben keine sensoren wir
spüren die radioaktivität nicht wir
wissen nicht was sie letztendlich
ausmacht und
gerade eltern von kindern haben
natürlich panik momente wenn allein nur
so an der uns ist kann eine
falschmeldung sein
irgendwo in die medien zu tage kommt und
wir haben in der schule für jede klasse
eine kiste gepackt wir haben vor allen
dingen becher die wir betrieb was
erfüllen können weil zunächst mal ist
das leitungswasser ja dann noch und
kontaminiert wer hat für jedes kind eine
maske
dies auch nutzen kann auf dem
nachhauseweg falls eben doch
radioaktivität da ist und und das ist
extrem wichtig wir haben uns gedanken
gemacht wie informieren wir eigentlich
die eltern darüber wo welches kind ist
das heißt es ist definiert an welcher
tür wie raus hängen wo welches kind sich
befindet und da gibt es zu jedem kind
einen entsprechenden aufkleber der dann
ausgefüllt wird beziehungsweise jedes
kind schreibt den namen drauf und klebt
den auf einen entsprechenden zettel und
zwar ganz einfach damit die unsicherheit
weg ist und deswegen bin ich dafür die
kraftwerke vorher abzuschalten und nicht
erst wenn es zu spät ist ich beschäftige
mich mit reaktor sicherheitsforschung
und ich bin überzeugt dass wir in
deutschland die sichersten kraftwerke
haben und ich deswegen denke dass wir
darüber nachdenken sollten ob wir die
letzten drei kraftwerke vorübergehend
noch brauchen da schlagen wirklich zwei
herzen in meiner brust ich bin der
meinung ja wir brauchen die
versorgungssicherheit wir brauchen die
kraftwerke aber ich bin auch ganz klar
der meinung nicht um jeden preis ich
habe über weihnachten das ist jetzt
glaube ich vier jahre her dass wir das
gemacht haben diese texte diese die
struktur die abläufe wirklich mal zu
papier gebracht man ist dann schon wenn
man das mal so drei vier stunden am
computer ab getippt hat ein anderer
mensch man denkt warum machst du das
überhaupt das ist doch sowieso gleich
alles vorbei und dass diese ängste diese
sorgen vor allen dingen vor dem
unbekannten vor der großen gefahr die da
vielleicht lauert vielleicht lauert sie
auch nicht aber ich bin der meinung dass
wir die ernst nehmen sollten die letzte
station unseres roadtrips gibt genau in
der mitte der ersten beiden stationen am
solarkraftwerk jülich treffen sich armin
und florian auch in der mitte in der
grauzone
ich glaube nur wir wo wir noch im moment
am weitesten auseinander sind ist
niefern die kernenergie einen beitrag
leisten kann bei der energiewende ja ich
freue mich dass wir uns
einig sind dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren eine gute idee ist und dass
die energiewende eine gute idee es das
wird noch ein bisschen dauern bis es
soweit ist und
hoffe so zu sagen gibt glaube ich auch
dass wir uns glaube ich auch eigentlich
dass sie wenn sie dann laufen in der
zeitung sie noch laufen dass sie da
sicher sind so sicher wie möglich
gehalten werden müssen und das
hoffentlich leute da sind die
rechtzeitig alarm schreiben wie seht ihr
das brauchen wir die atomenergie
schreibt es uns in die kommentare
und wenn ihr wissen wollt was das
problem mit den endlagern ist wieso wir
in deutschland mehr angst vor kernkraft
haben als in anderen ländern und welche
grauzonen die atomenergie noch so mit
sich bringt dann schaut euch jetzt die
ganze doku atomkraft nein danke in der
zdf mediathek an